we're on problem 19 problem 19.
if k and x and y are positive numbers
satisfy let's see what did they write
they wrote
x
to the minus four third
x to the minus four third
is equal to k to the minus two
y to the four y to the positive four
third
is equal to n squared
what is
x y
to the minus two thirds
in terms of n
and k
all right so we just have to rewrite
this in terms of n and k so let me write
it big
so x y to
x y
to the minus
two thirds
that equals
x
to the minus two thirds
that's x to the minus two thirds
times y
to the minus two thirds
we know what x to the four thirds is
this is what i wrote here might not be
that
legible sorry
so this is a four right we know what x
to the minus four thirds is so can we
write this
rewrite this as you know x to the minus
four thirds to something
well sure we could write rewrite this
this term right here we could write this
as let me write right below it so you
don't get too confused as x
to the minus four thirds
and then you raise that to the one half
power
this is the same thing as this how do i
know that well if i multiply
four-thirds times one-half because i'm
raising something to an exponent and
then that to an exponent if i multiply
minus four-thirds times one-half
i get minus two thirds right the the
four you know this two cancels out this
becomes a two and this is what i get
you can try it out
similarly
i wanna write this second term
i'm gonna do it in green
this y to the minus two thirds i know
what y to the four thirds is right so i
want to write it as
y to the four thirds
to some other power
so four thirds times what is equal to
minus two-thirds
well four-thirds times minus one-half
and you could try it out
four-thirds times minus one-half is
equal to minus two-thirds right you get
positive times a negative equals a
negative
and then the four and the two end up
just
the two sorry i'm burping
so what does this become well we know
what x to the minus four thirds is right
x to the minus four thirds is equal to k
to the minus two
so this e that first term is equal to
this
is equal to k that's too dark
all right k
to the minus 2
and then we're raising that to the
one-half
right that's the same one half right
there
and then y to the four thirds what's y
to the four thirds well that's n squared
that's n squared
and then
that's of course the minus one half
and then we can multiply what's k what's
minus two times one half well it's just
minus one so it's k
to the minus one and that's what's two
times minus one half what's minus one
again so k
minus one n to the minus 1
and that's the same thing as
1 over
k n or 1 over n k
which is choice
a
and i now i just realized that there's
actually an easier way to do that we
could have done it like this
we could have just said
let me see let me erase this stuff just
because it's i think good for you to
know the easier way instead of the way i
just showed you how to do it
let me erase all of this
i think we would have saved some steps
and more intuitive
let me erase all of this i just wanted
to keep what i had written before
erase erase erase
okay i think that's good enough
you could just ignore the stuff on the
right
so we could have simplified these ahead
of time we could have said x to the
minus four third is equal to k to the
minus two
if we raised both of these to the
one-half power
if we raise both of these to the
one-half power
to the one-half power
we would get
what minus four-thirds times one-half is
we've got x to the minus two-thirds
is equal to what's k negative two times
one half it's negative one right would
have equal k to the negative one and
similarly
if we had raised
y to the four thirds
equals n squared
if we had raised both of those to the
minus one-half
right if you do something on one side of
the equation you have to do on the other
then you would have gotten
y to the minus two-thirds
is equal to
n to the minus one
and then this would have been really
easy to solve x y to the minus two
thirds is the same thing as x to the
minus two thirds
times y to the minus two thirds
x to the minus two thirds is k to the
minus one
and y to the two y to the negative two
thirds is n to the minus one so it would
have been k to the minus one n to the
minus one
that's one over n k
well i guess in hindsight i could say
this was easier but you know the way we
did it would have also worked and you
really don't know sometimes which one
will be the shortcut when you do it the
first time but either way could have
worked you could have simplified it
ahead of time if you saw that if you had
seen that you wanted to get it into
two-thirds not four-thirds because they
had a two-thirds here or you could just
go the way we did it the first time
either way works
next problem
problem number 20.
okay functions of f and g so i'm going
to do some drawing here hopefully i have
enough time
except to draw two of them
so let me that one's going to be for f
and this one's going to be for g
this is going to be for
g and what points are there
so
f of x let's see there's like you go
f x has two points back and it
intersects there and intersects at the
point
-1 comma 1 2 3 so it intersects here
and then it goes through the origin
and then it goes to 1 minus 3 so that's
1 2 3
1. so it goes here
and then it goes at 2 comma 0 and
intersects here so let me try to draw
that
so the graph looks something like this
it goes up
intersects this point comes down to the
origin goes down here
and then goes up like that
that is y equals f of x
y equals f of x
now what does g of x do
what does g of x do
g of x
goes to two comma one
so
one two
comma one
two comma one as to four minus fives two
three four
one two three four five four minus five
four minus five and then it goes back up
so it looks something like this it goes
down
comes up like that
just back up like that the figures above
show the graph of the functions f and g
the function f is defined by
so this one f is f of x
is equal to
x to the third
minus 4x
the function g of x
g of x
is equal to f of x plus h
plus k where h and k are constants
what is the value of k
so essentially what they're saying is g
of x is f of x shifted up or down by
some value k right because when you add
a constant to a function you're just
you're just moving it up or down by some
value k
and when you add h when you add h that
means you're shifting it you're shifting
it to the
let me make sure i get this right so if
i if it was x minus h that means you're
shifting it to the right by h
so x plus h means you're shifting it to
the left shifting it to the left by h
by h
so k is the easy one
right this point corresponds to this
point so how much did we shift down this
is the point
this is the point negative one comma
three
and this is the point
this is the point two comma one
two comma 1.
so we went from y equals 3 to y equals 1
right so we shifted down by 2.
so k is going to be
minus 2 and similarly you could do it
with this point
so k is equal to minus 2.
now we have to figure out how much we
shifted left or right so same order
these are the corresponding points
because you can kind of look at them in
the graph
so we went from -1
to positive 2. we went from
-1 to positive 2. so we shifted to the
right we shifted to the right by 3
right and you could do the same thing
with this point here at the bottom we
shifted to the right by 3.
so if i wanted to shift f x to the right
by 3 i would write like this f of x
of x
minus
three
that's how i would shift a function to
the right by three
they're saying plus h so h has to be
minus three h is minus three
and minus three times minus two well
that's positive six which is choice e